on this week's show what are the best
areas for serviced accommodation in the
news the property market in London is
set to ton positive according to latest
reports and we're gonna be answering all
your property related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends hi I'm Russell
each time our cunningham welcome to the
property investors podcast so yes give
me a really good show there's some
interesting news coming up there is just
about just about you we could we get
cracking into this week's been pretty
cool so I've just literally we're at
crash course at the minute we're just
been doing a crash course ongoing at the
minute
we've nipped with NIST helped out to get
this done but yeah crash course this
week lots of training lots of events
it's been really really busy really
hectic what yourself good yeah I've just
been in the office well it's been it's
been a busy week yeah a good week it's
very good wave it's been a busy week I
went to go into the every month
simmer okay you ever been to one of them
so basically it's like a normal cinema
well apart from rather than having
individual seats they have sofas for -
okay and like a little table and then
they bring food you can order food like
pizza be either beer
did you it's like the best cinema ever
yeah I mean that's just like a normal
cinema to be honest like cinemas if you
upgrade to VIP in the cinemas actually
incidentally I went to the cinema Lalla
week and me and Rick went to watch
Cameron well it was watched but we went
to mean Ricky win and if you upgrade
that you can pay to upgrade to VIP and
you get a big sort of lounger seats with
a recline and all that sort of stuff and
then it was expensive it was like 80
quid for two tickets and like you get
you get to go into the VIP lounge where
you get like dinner and stuff at that
was a Thorat did you eat dinner during
the film well yeah you can bring it in
table so yes
not table service not to me so it sounds
a little bit different so you didn't get
like table service bringing your beer
and stuff come through you know no and
it may it was there like before the film
started I've never been only a film that
you can watch Judy no no never heard of
it what did you go so how does the
camera bed you never you cause you never
heard of my hustler we went see hustler
hustler hustler yeah it's about Jennifer
with new Jennifer Lopez film it's about
Jennifer Lopez mmm yeah it's really good
film is it about us that's high no it's
about how when she is she's she's
playing about six seven years ago you
actually watched this listen about six
seven years ago in America there was a
couple of strippers and they were
hustling people and they were drugging
them up before they went into strip club
and then they were swiping their cards
for like $50,000 and things are and it
was there was a couple of people done it
and they've got they've got they're in
prison for it now and it's a reenactment
of that it's actually quite interested
and it was like there was there was
there was dudes like done for like 75
grand on a night out on their American
Express's and things are and these these
four ladies they orchestrated all what
put in prison for it but yeah we just
all about that it's really good yeah
point was with the cinema is that you
pay a bit more but the service was great
so they had like a guy that came out it
was a war welcome to film will be
starting shortly if you yeah it was like
it was not next level sort of service
how much tickets not that expensive I
think attempt about 35 quid
yeah vision we're looking at about 2500
so it's about an extra 10 amaz have got
very expensive yeah plus plus then
obviously the food about 70 quid
go where where was the cinema where was
actual theater you went Charles cross
okay it's not far from where I live yeah
awesome look every visit we've been busy
we've been busy watching films
forgetting what they're about that sort
of stuff you know the usual okay it was
like weeks ago what it meant
well the more we talk about no so
service combination yes this is
something that we you know we get asked
a lot about in terms of your are you
know if that's probably one of the most
what made a sort of think of it is
literally people are posting today yeah
on the group saying like all had watch
at the area I don't know it was a good
area I even hope to find the best area
people people get stuck on where to go
because obviously buy a little rent hi
is by law rent hi so you the houses
you're typically looking out or going to
be up north because of the lower priced
and you can still rent and for a higher
amount of money and so right if you're
doing service accommodation it is highly
likely you're going to be doing it on a
rent to rent model what suppose
obviously got two options that you have
it yeah the majority pulled an SEO doing
I'm gonna rent around places because
there's easy an easy out
it's also easier to buy a buy to that
apartment yeah and then rent it out
that's easy as well I agree with you but
it it may be it's easy access for a lot
of people that maybe can't afford to
deposits for three hundred thousand
pound partment and I don't Chelmsford or
wherever they may be because obviously
if rent to rent to get more miter saw
service accommodation to get more money
you you're typically going to be in this
entire area nicer areas much more
expensive to be like hotels are more
expensive so you to buy them as you need
a massive deposit so you'll be better
off doing them on a write interim basis
if you can we talk about this that went
to rent revolution so like think about
where do you live where's the nearest
nicest
city to where you live and that we see
it has to have three things has to be
near where you live so do you think it's
important it's near where you live I
think yes because the way we teach essay
is that the you if it's your first one
and you're getting involved in it after
you've become compliantly you should run
it yourself for six months to get to
understand how it all works
because before you systemize it you need
to have a really really good
understanding of how these systems work
and how you can best take yourself out
of the business because the idea is
we're trying to create people we're
trying to teach people how to have
passive income that's fine but the thing
is it's very you you should like take
you in it's like ours in our business
yeah
we don't give it to somebody else to do
until we've done it and know how to do
it agreed a great yeah so we would say
your first service commendation you
should be running it yourself to
understand how how the linen works to
understand how the the changeovers work
to understand how the keysafe work
sometimes sound everything all the
processes once you've understood it then
systemize it and that's the way we do it
that's the way we recommend only for a
couple of months we're not going to do
this forever just a couple of months get
used to it and get get good understand
and then systemize it you can systemize
it very very well but so on that note I
would see you it wants to be in the
nearest city to you somewhere that's
city center it's busy and it's got
things going on it's actually something
there's something going on there so like
for instance are certain cities up north
where there's just nothing going on so I
wouldn't put anything in there like
where places like hull III can't see
service accommodation making very much
money in a place as a whole and if I'm
wrong I'm wrong and please tell me if
I'm wrong I don't mind but there's lots
of cities up north it like I we Jake
we're always going right where should we
go for a nice business trip let's go to
whole conversation is it right of course
you know why I find really interesting
is when you go to like these cities
there is holidaymakers they're like
tourists not not whole but like like
burning on things are can you imagine
being like and whatever and thinking
having you having you sit there with
your family around the dinner table and
say oh we're gonna hold you this year
weird you wanna go Birmingham people
travel to England for a brew at the
moment right so I'm not looking good I
don't know where it wears a craphole and
wears good they'd be disappointed when
you walk up at home with me I suppose
I'm gonna go so I'm gonna go so get to
Rome that's a bit different to Hull I'm
gonna go to Rome in Italy all in in let
us say o someone that way to go to Rome
alright and then we're looking on the
fYI I've got houses in whole and I love
whole but I just it's not a whole new
destination and then I was widen the
search I thought I maybe explore a bit
of the real Italy and I found somewhere
I went they think you could do that and
you could you could end up in the hole
awesome wherever you could right let's
get back to the point city centre has to
be busy there has to be things going on
right so just think where do you live
like so for me I live in North London
and I've got lots of there's lots of
options around London for service
accommodation they don't fall under the
90-day rule there's lots of cities just
outside London it don't fund that aren't
affected by any regulation so I've got
so many options but let's just say you
live up in like friends that's where I
used to live Northampton and the nearest
city
I've got Oxford Northampton which is
yeah you've got north happens in itself
you were Oxford you've got Milton key
offices you just copied everything I say
we take to us so I just thought are we
kind of saying oh is that the thing so
you've got Northampton Oxford Milton
Keynes you've got lots of cities nearby
that accommodation would work very well
and so you don't need to be driving far
far away okay so pizza so big a bigger
city
yep any city nearby where you live as
long as it's busy and nice yep
so so you gotta pick a nice busy a nice
busy city near where you live yeah so
you in Scotland would you do that
there's very very nice places in
Scotland or you Scottish viewers like
you find him and you thumbs down on
finding thumbs down on this video now
it's gonna be now he loves Scotty loves
font he's just talking cuz I'm Scottish
Edinburgh Edinburgh hair
lissa in Scotland has lots of places at
work very well for holiday lights as
well but service accommodation Edinburgh
Glasgow Aberdeen and there's places all
those lots of business grow up there
being a main the positivists what's the
biggest use of service accommodation who
uses it the most categorically business
people
the businesspeople so whatever there's
stuff going on big cities with business
you're gonna get you're gonna find
you're gonna have use now another way to
do it and I find this quite useful start
looking around all the corporate
websites things like Premier Inn Holiday
Inn Express cost a coffee Starbucks all
these big chains and find out where they
are developing and where they're
building because if they're it I can
rest assured right if you're thinking of
a city and you're worrying a bit well
it's gonna work or not and premiere in a
build in a hotel there it will work
trust me because premiere end their main
clientele is holidaymakers and if you I
spent a lot of time driving around the
country looking at houses and I used to
stay in lots of premier inns and believe
me a lot of them in the bigger cities
it's sometimes very difficult to get in
a few big last minute because people are
gonna end up buying like an apartment
now right off a service station or
something I've just seen you think about
where's getting developed what's
happening whereas premier inns getting
built okay so you make companies early
where they feel because they've done
their research they've they've checked
for a footfall they've checked for
demand they've checked for use just
don't need to recreate the wheel and use
there they've got teams of people who
doing the research supportive people
that watch this now for real got a
couple of cities in mind when we're near
they we're near wet nearby where they
live
yeah so bang yeah okay Birmingham that's
a Oxford whether you let those do for
Northampton's the people are now
thinking Oxford Northampton then what
next what else do we do what else
because how do we know if it's gonna
work it's not gonna work okay there's a
really good website yep
err DNA as a our DNA so Russell will
translate that yeah the reason is so
there's nothing wrong with Alastair so
we Scottish accent the vowels are very
hard to distinguish so it spells things
out so it's err a IR DNA there yo he's
got the DNA deal otherwise it sounds
like a
DNA which you know it's difficult anyway
err DNA if you jump on our DNA you don't
have to pay at them and it's free to use
you can type in any signal you can do a
phrase that you're paid yeah so the
minute is free so you can do a basic
search in any city in the world and it
will give you the stats for service
accommodation you can once you've chosen
your specific area you can pay for a
monthly report in that specific area
which goes into a much much greater
detail and that price varies from city
to city so when I was doing I was
looking at Milton Keynes the to get
Milton Keynes was 32 pounds a month and
that gives you a daily update on what's
going on the the sort of properties that
are working very well so it tells you
like how many properties are one bedroom
two bedroom three bedroom four bedroom
what rents out the best how much the
average rate is occupancy rates things
that I it tells you a lot about each
specific area they've done the research
above so they did you have to pay for
that so yeah Denis it so I mean air DNA
very very good very good
ok brilliant so you can check websites
like that have a look on places like
booking comm absolute a B&B have a look
at the general demands on on Lake Sebu
can calm and there being me you can find
an apartment if you want to book in that
area and just look at the calendar
because it you can access the calendar
going forward or you can select dates
and see if it's been boot or get a Trank
a feeling for the consensus of is the
property available constantly for the
next two months if it is then maybe
there's not a lot of demand there if you
you're putting in dates and it's sold
out then is it's a good sign for you
that there's demand and the two things
that you're really looking for when
you're doing this research is number one
occupancy right yeah and number two the
amount per night yeah that people are
paying their the to their the two things
that you kind of wants yeah one Jack
aren't they sir in regards talking
mister right
I mean service accommodation the
occupancy pay is actually really high
isn't it it's really I we when the rent
rent rent revolution we work everything
on fifty percent so if you they do all
your songs do your calculations
and if you do not break even at 50%
occupancy rate we advise perhaps not
going ahead all definitely well we said
this up - it's up to you a decision at
the end the day but we say we wouldn't
go ahead if you don't break even at 50%
then we wouldn't go through go through
with it
no we have had people that do they don't
break even till 70% but they still go
ahead and are still making money but
that we like to be very considered as a
risky then it makes a hard work and
risky yeah but like Ricky has properties
and Milton Keynes they're running at 90
90 to 95 percent occupancy very high
occupancy and he's making like 12 to 15
under plan a month per property so
they're out there you find them in the
right area make sure if things right
yeah they'll make money so what would
you say then and we got what we kind of
looking for in terms of nightly rate
mm-hmm because what for example
something like Wolverhampton obviously
we you know we stir our office was there
and the nightly rates were just when I
last my state over Wolverhampton when I
was in office for a couple of days I
stayed in our near our service
accommodation apartment and it was
formerly a hate gym all and they just
made it into they made it into it was
six bed hitch more they made it into six
bed that might say okay but it was 25
pounds a night yeah but still for 25 it
was not so bad is it cuz you've got 25
yeah that's what quickly work that out
first
at full occupancy be 25 times 650 pound
the night at times it's four and a half
grand yeah so because they've split into
six really it's hundred fifty-pound an
item yeah
so yeah you if it's if it's single
occupancy like a one-bedroom apartment I
wouldn't be interested unless it was at
least 90 pound a night I wouldn't like
any less than that just it just doesn't
seem worth the hassle no move the
cleaning costs didn't cost a is the same
yeah the cleaning costs around offer
yeah Don don't you don't include them I
made the mistake of including them when
I first started doing this so I'm a it
was annoying and so just to make sure
you add them on and but yeah they I
wouldn't get involved in this you
getting at least 90 pounds and I
least and also a little tip is is is
with your nightly rigs look at what's
happening over the the next year in this
in the area like what events are coming
to the town is state for instance
Silverstone so all the properties around
Silverstone the rates triple the golf
from 100-pound the night hundred and
fifty per night to 400 and 450 pound the
night but just know what's going on so
if you've got property like for instance
near I don't know a good word so you've
got Goodwood Festival prices go up or
that first of all you go to Nate what's
that Creamfields I went Creamfields all
the musical festivals the prices go up
what's going on in the area that you can
increase the prices and do it don't be
scared to do it just want the prices up
because you'll get people like Nick
going and crashing your house trashing
your apartment I've done them too much
drink I'm kiddin II would never do that
we might go on okay brilliant so I've
written and we'll write average
occupancy right so nightly pan they're
like well you're looking at for
occupancy oh I won't do it unless it's
at least fifty but 50 percent you know
what I don't mean I don't mean what you
break-even point is I mean okay yes 17
area I think seventy percent minimum
seventy seventy five percent the average
across the UK 75 you want to be at least
seven you want to be getting at least
seventy I wouldn't I'd be happy with
seventeen but then people say that they
want a hundred percent and then I think
yeah that's fine but only if you've got
really really good systems in place
because if you've got something to
checking in in like checking out and
checking on every single day you need
good teams in place to make sure that
everything's seamless and smooth and the
cleanings getting done the laundries are
getting changed everything to be
seamless let's just don't register I
think it is unreal even hotel store top
100 percent no well hotels have less on
average the service combination yeah so
but even great hotels don't have 100%
mm-hmm yeah well hopefully that's given
you some sort of tips on how to find the
area choose a a big area near you do bit
research a DNA booking calm look out for
things like these that the average price
is the occupancy rate work out what you
get
it's gonna be and if it's above those
sort of figures that's probably it's
probably a good goer the other good
thing is we doing on a rent to rent yeah
as long as you put in the contract that
you've got a break clause yeah if it
doesn't work you're not taking too much
of a risk you can always you mess up and
accidentally get it in hole you think
holes gonna be great and then you go
ahead and you do it and it doesn't work
then just you can pull out a line it's
gonna get no bookings you should get
summoned you know what do we call that
what do as a renter rent before you
commit try before you buy
oh it's not really uh something we call
that's quite quite famous saying there
but we've tagged it to red dress up so I
see it well all right it's now time for
this
[Music]
okay so in the news this week proximate
property market is set to turn positive
in London accordingly index so here's
basically the rationale behind it
basically the rents in London of begin
to rise yeah which means that investors
are like try a car thinking we need to
get back into London to make take
advantage of the of the rise and
therefore it's gonna make the house
prices go up so now could be a very good
time to buy in London because number one
the rents are gonna go up she's good and
number two he capital appreciation well
then go up yeah well then go up as well
overall great lenders price correction
is completely says all the top foreign
boroughs and then essence market in
terms of rental growth will soon
translate into top performing sales
market because the sales have something
a bit last few years but the Reds go for
sales follow so I wonder obviously with
bricks it the lumen and 31st of October
I Rex it have you not heard about that
no is that is that a breakfast here it's
a breakfast cereal yeah it's like wait a
bit anyway breaks it breaks it's looming
around the corner so I wonder what
effect that's going to have on this
because there's lots and lots of people
that are let's face it no we do not know
what is going to happen after break so
even the most intelligent financial
minds out there have not to scooby-doo
about this lunch probably lunch yeah it
would be like every other day but my
point being is we nobody knows so you're
getting if I don't we don't want none of
us watch the news however I have tuned
into a few programs recently about
brakes just to see what the hell was
going on and what people are saying
about it and it's amazing how to like
top financial guys have such different
opinions about things so who nobody
knows nobody knows and me Boris at the
helm like it's going to be interesting
you know I think I'm sure it will but so
maybe that's going to have an effect on
this the general consensus is there's
gonna be a dip
not not an increase yeah
they've also piloted the worst area okay
where's up I can see and I've got houses
they're great have ya humba humba bridge
hull sorry man so so not only should you
not buy an office accommodation you
shouldn't buy an old basically this
podcast is designed to hate on the whole
no no no no I've got some really good
friends up there and I got some really
good properties up there and the East of
England how asking prices was down 2.9
percent over the last 12 months and down
that they're falling half a percent a
month at the moment Wow interestingly
because East of England was going up for
the last so for five years mmm yeah very
interesting so what was your take on
this news article what do you think
about London would you invest in London
in a minute probably not no I would I
would have actually interestingly I'm
looking at a buyer for a briefing on
steel in London at the minute and sin
Jones would I'll do that yeah do it by
refocus yes it's a chunk speak about it
I want to come about yeah I only come
about it two days ago how much in well
it's purchase price of 750 so how much
that so well not gonna get somebody
right okay I'm really looking about
seventy-five thousand but the house is
worth 1.1 1.2 so there's a chunk of
money that we made did will keep posted
but that's not it's yeah cool all right
anyway it's now time for your questions
and our answers
[Music]
okay so the first question that's come
in is from Brad the Hitman Hart he says
can deal sourcing be passive Hey hey
Brad how you doin bro yeah and so to
begin with no you're gonna have to do it
to learn the ropes and to learn learn
how we do it so you've got to do it very
very very much yourself once you get
good at it and once you get systems in
place and teams in place yeah it's
absolutely passive if you want it to be
it's the same as can any bit it's a
business a business business be passive
I would say a business can be 99%
passive yeah unless you're just like a
shareholder obviously well really about
to beta source beta source is for me
it's 99% passive my involvement and
better sourced as I have our meeting
with the operations manager once a month
we have regular daily daily phone calls
and daily whatsapp messages
plus all the viewings no no no no hold
on you do daily calls daily calls as in
so max max takes me this morning and
said just let you know can you just
check the bank for this that's it
so I've been sure that we're talking
like a minute but it's not I'm not out
physically doing it I spend less than
half an hour
probably I would say I spend listen I
know we're a week on the business okay
so like I say it's 99 percent passive
it's not a hundred percent passive I
literally take a few voice notes
throughout the day sometimes I don't
even hear from them and then we have a
meeting once a month and we have every
every few days so every few days we have
a forum call or in 90% passive isn't it
every few days we have a phone call if
he needs to contact me through our daily
contact davia what's that bye what's up
on voice notes or text message and
that's it but it takes I would say
maximum 95% person I would say maximum
an hour a week I spend on berry sauce
pushing meter plus the meeting yeah at
the end of the month which is normally
over dinner and then we go out for a big
go out for a few drinks it's more it's
like a meeting social it's not me is it
yeah did you get taken advantage of by
do you get drugged up and someone use
your American Express card No
oh no max my over okay actually had my
business card I explains it all the
money go no no yeah it can be passive
rule all right there you go if they go
brass that's it can be passive not
actually you man cuz your breath to hit
my heart you can definitely do it sir
just it's I we started off and I said
right the first question from Brad Hart
and I read the question and he made me
cut it to then say Brad the Hitman Hart
just so you know so next question from
Darren Andrews you got any fancy name
for him no there are none ders not he's
our hit man or anything he's just Darren
do you know why we said Brad the Hitman
Hart Bret the Hitman Hart its Bret the
Hitman Hart yeah yeah WUF like really
I'd say every week kidding go Darren
Andrews Northwest compared to Northeast
for bio foolish finance thanks guys keep
it the great work yeah we'd gone
Northwest yeah me too Manchester crew
called we've just read that northeast is
probably a bad time to do it Northwest I
would stay in losing half a percent a
month at the moment so yeah Northwest
bro Javon Marsh overseas investor here
what do you see the biggest weakness and
strength of an overseas investor my view
I guess is asked a question these answer
his own question so it might be we might
just [ __ ] MIT just read it out yep
so here we go so my view so this is Jeff
and Marcia's view this is the Russell
leads outside Cunningham and Jeff and
Marsh podcast yeah
strengths number one blocking out the
noise brexit where's that strength
property hate and the UK news presents
its what saying it's been overseas you
don't you know Joe how you just
mentioned early you don't really watch
the news yeah you're not subjected to
all the okay number two lower exchange
rates at the moment yeah weaknesses
number one speed of purchase even when
buying through a limited company when
they find out you're from overseas he
takes ages and number two
unable to view the property prior to
purchase means a finder a trust or a
trustworthy sorcerer ie better sourced
wins my vote air boom shacka interested
to hear if you we have any other
strengths that perhaps I'm not utilizing
yes keep up the great work
both Cheers Jaron listen right I work
with many overseas investors that are
all in the same boat urine the they
can't view the properties because
they're overseas they don't want to view
the properties because they're overseas
the the the purchase is longer give give
max a call a better source and he'll put
you in touch with their guy who helps
facility getting your funds and getting
your company that set up in the UK and
we will only really deal with an
overseas investor when we know their
funds are in the UK because of the time
it can take to get your funds here so
when you're looking to purchase give max
a call if you want to go through us his
number zero seven seven zero four zero
nine one two six to give him a call
he'll put you in touch with our guy and
what he does is he facilitates getting
your wherever you're from your currency
to UK currency and in the UK and does
all the anti-money laundering checks he
does everything and he can assist with
holding the money and saying helping you
set up an account here and set up our
company here so any of us Travis sent
you can think of no that was just my
advice on it but as he got his question
was is there any of our strengths he's
not utilizing no I think sorry May
you've got nothing I think you you're in
a good position in the sense that if
sometimes it's good not to be and not to
be here because you can put your trust
in other people and you can just rely on
their expertise to find you a good deal
so the fact that you're not here it
might be good I've got many overseas
investors I've never even been to the UK
to see the properties and the properties
get done you're not involved so
sometimes that by the fact that you're
not directly involved means there's one
less person involved in everything and
it speeds things up so you
your strength bro is that you're not
involved you're involved you're paying
the bills and you get the profit from it
but you're not physically here like
having your input on things so do you
not mean like we've got an answer from
China and called Sharon and and and she
she she's invested lots of protein lots
of properties with ours and with all the
people she doesn't see them but the
whole transaction is so smooth that was
Sharon yeah Sean yeah normal Chinese no
no no she's expats and my point being is
Hong she's not in bare and she's not
involved in the protest she literally
says look I want that house there's the
money sorted out we do everything we do
the build we do everything and we will
then just say look we even found the
tenants for her it's on everything and
it's just easier it's actually easier
because when you have too many people
involved takes too long that was just a
hint a good hint I got it I got it
one more final one okay and this is very
apt for talked about today guys I don't
just talk about rent to service
accommodation quite a lot but never buy
to service accommodation all that
difficulties of a mortgage we're
planning to let it out a service
conversion great product that's by the
way you love to very inspiring
thank you Jake we touched on that
earlier yeah I think it's mainly because
the most people the because they're more
expensive apartments that it's a kind of
or more sensitive places it kind of
limits and you've got to in Birmingham
saying days past you know great yeah
great yeah but there are obviously
problems in the mortgages we've got the
same problems with the mortgages when
you do rent rent rent as well so it
doesn't make much difference really
but guys thank you very to the questions
we really appreciate you tuning in we'll
be back next Saturday at 7 p.m. please
do not forget to subscribe we love you
and we'll see you soon
see you guys
[Music]
[Applause]